vous êtes un grand médiologue de
carrière pascal votre première
apparition je crois officielle à la
télévision mais tu vois un peu énervé
mais je suis pas mal énervé en fait j'ai
des papillons dans l'estomac nous avons
quand même des grossistes y ait de
belles grosses truites un petit peu
comme avec la météo au début on avait
des petites gouttes comme ça on verra
des grosses gouttes comme ceux du grand
souk ahras attend monts et cory martin p
te rappelles tu que c'est à cause de ma
vie d'homme que tu es rentrée radio
canada quand j'ai eu ma première fille
écoute tu as fait une carrière et 40
droits ta retraite je t'en serai tout
une âme histoire salut pascal un petit
mot pour te dire vraiment un grand merci
je te dois beaucoup tu as été un
véritable mentor pour moi merci pour
tout ce que tu m'as appris j'ai été
choyé de te côtoyer pendant toutes ces
années
bush de fanatiques qu il soit le
batman
[Musique]
de ton sens de l'humour est quand même
bien présents que ce soit en nombre mais
aussi à l'extérieur ta passion pour la
langue française dans ces cas musique
classique était qu'elle était en tant
que métérologue hors pair j'ai ça je
veux tu fais une source d'inspiration
très prononcé pour moi et pour cela je
te l'ont remercié ce côté très relax que
tu as justement de raconter la météo
l'espèce de coolitude de pascal
yiacouvakis je te remercie de m'avoir
transmis soeur
déjà 5 cm à montréal on est en route
pourraient facilement 25 pour la région
métropolitaine
toute cette pluie qui est tombée à
retomber beaucoup il faut le dire oui au
oui à montréal on a reçu 80 mm depuis
je voulais voir ce qu'on a reçu je vous
montre ça tout de suite vous voyez à la
le premier lit dans basse et le grésil
et au dessus il ya une couche de glace
le verglas et on attend à peu près 10 à
20 millimètres de verglas
supplémentaires chez de l'eau la place à
de la pluie verglaçante vous le voyez
pourrait donc c'est l'avenue
verglaçantes mellieha du brésil tantôt
il a pu briser une quelques verglaçantes
il ya plus de place dans 40 que de
grésil a lancé mauvaise ou très mauvaise
un bon choix parce que j'ai eu une
carrière absolument exemplaire une
maîtrise exceptionnelle de ta science un
propos toujours nuancé accessible direct
bref ce sont là des ingrédients de la
communication et tri possèdent tous et
puis je garde ce très très très agréable
souvenir des moments nous avons
travaillé pas seulement moment du
verglas mais après à chaque fois c'était
plein soleil alors qu'est-ce que je te
souhaite je te souhaite du bonheur
beaucoup de bonheur du plaisir et merci
pour ta très grande contribution avec
mon amitié pascal
[Applaudissements]
waouh une carrière pascal
exceptionnelle celle adressée merci bon
tu es pascal un grand vulgarisateur
scientifique y en a eu dans l'histoire
du québec tu fais partie de ceux là
soient fiers
prophétisant et merci beaucoup n'ont
toute l'équipe là d'avoir su nous
expliquer les affaires pas mal compliqué
j'ai essayé j'ai essayé mais ça c'est
mon petit côté professeurs quand je vous
dis je suis en 7 6 4 ans donc ça mais d
un peu a expliqué les choses puis
communiqué depuis aisément possible
aller directement à ce qui était
important bon bah oui merci beaucoup